troops tanks and weapons are on the move
across europe as nato continues to
reinforce its eastern front its member
states who are closest to russia now the
alliance has activated elements of its
response force thousands of extra troops
over a hundred jets are on high alert
120 warships are in position nato
leaders met by secure video conference
for the first time since the start of
the russian invasion as fears grow that
the ukrainian capital could be taken
soon
how fearful are you about the possible
fall of key and if we move to a
resistance insurgency type situation
what support can nato then give what we
have seen is that um the ukrainian
forces are
fighting bravely and are actually able
to
inflict damage uh on the invading
russian uh forces
but again it is
a very fluid and uh and
an evolving situation
nato allies expressed at the
summit today
that they
provide support to ukraine they are
ready to continue to provide support to
ukraine
here at nato headquarters the plan is to
fully protect their members on the
eastern front the country's closest to
russia but at the same time they're
sending a message to president putin
you're getting exactly what you said you
didn't want an increased nato presence
on your doorstep
it's part of a coordinated effort the
european union was invited to the
virtual nato meeting
at the same time eu foreign ministers
met in brussels to agree a fresh round
of sanctions the third in just three
days
this time they decided to directly
sanction the personal assets of
president putin and his foreign minister
sergey lavrov
james bay's al jazeera brussels